اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات نبدا
بالعناوين
للمره الاولى منذ بدء الحرب بوتين المطلوب
للجنائيه الدوليه تجولوا في ماريوبول
العالم المخططين المختصين والعمليه الطول
نائب وقائد العمليات المشتركه العراقيه
للعربيه نهايه داعش تحتاج لوقت
لقاء خماسي في شرم الشيخ لبحث التهدئه بين
الفلسطينيين واسرائيل بمشاركه امريكيه
وسط مناورات عسكريه بين واشنطن وسول كوريا
الشماليه تطلق صاروخا بالستيا واليابان
تندد
قام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بزياره
عمل الى ماريوبل في اقليم دنياتس لتفقدي
مواقع المدينه ومرافقها ووفقا بيان
الكرامل فان بوتين سافر الى ماريوبل
مروحيه ثم استقل سياره التجول بها في
انحاء المدينه وبين الحين والاخر توقف
للتحدث الى السكان واشار الكرملين الى ان
بوتين التقى بالقياده العليا لعمليته
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك رئيس
هيئه الاركان العامه
المسؤول عن حرب موسكو في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اعتبرت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا ان اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مذكره التوقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
قرارا بالغ الاهميه وشددت كولونيا على ان
هذه الخطوه رادعه لانها تعني ان اي شخص
مسؤول عن اي نوع من الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
يجب ان يحاسب بغض النظر عن وضعه او منصبه
وينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد يعني
بوتين يصل الى القرن في الذكرى التاسعه
على ضمها ماء الرسائل من وراء هذه الرساله
او الزياره
مرحبا راويه من جديد نعم يعني هو الاحتفال
بذكرى التاسعه لضم شبه جزيره القرم الى
روسيا الامه كما تتحدث موسكو بوتين طبعا
وصل الى هناك يوم امس للتاكيد على ضروره
ومحوريه هذا الموضوع خاصه ان هذه الزياره
جاءت بعد مذكره الاعتقال من محكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه بما يخص قضايا يعني
تتعلق بالازمه الاوكرانيه راويه طبعا وجود
بوتين في تلك المنطقه في هذا التوقيت طبعا
كان الذي حدث هو اعلان موسكو عن زياره
الرئيس الصيني في العشرين من الشهر الجاري
وحتى الثاني والعشرين عقبها طبعا هذه
المذكره ومن ثم ينطلق بوتين ليتحدث على ما
يبدو انه اتجه نحو ايصال رساله بانه قادر
على تحرك مسيطر على الوضع في الجنوب
الاوكراني ان كان في القرن وان كان في
مناطق اخرى شاهدنا طبعا وتوقفنا الحديث
معك حول جولات بوتين في ماريوت للعديد من
المناطق والنقاط الحيويه في هذه المدينه
الان طبعا تتضح من الفيديوهات النقاط التي
زارها بوتين طبعا توجه برفقه نائب ووزير
الحكومه الروسي الى منطقه المطار زاد
المطار في هذه المدينه والتقارير التي
قدمت له تتحدث عن اعاده اعماره وتقديمه
للبدء باطلاق الرحلات الداخليه الى الداخل
الروسي او الى الخارج في عام
2025 طبعا من المنظر ومن المشهد ومن الحرب
التي شهدتها ماريوبل لا يمكن التكهم بان
فتره عامين هي كافيه لبناء مطار او اعاده
هيكلته من جديد لكن التقارير التي قدمت
لبوتين تتحدث عن هذا الشيء ايضا طبعا
بوتين زارا احد المجمعات السكنيه التي تم
بناؤها من السفر على انقاد هذه الحرب طبعا
تحدثت بوتين مع السكان المحليين في تلك
المناطق وتحدث عن ضروره تقديم المساعدات
الاقتصاديه بما في ذلك القروض ليتمكن
الرجال الاعمال القائمين في تلك المناطق
واصحاب طبعا التجارات الصغيره التي تبدا
من المحاله التجاريه وتنتهي بالاعمال
اليدويه للقيام باعمال يمكنها اعاده ضخ
الدماء الى المدينه واعاده الوضع الى ما
كان عليه قبل هذه الحربويه عبد الجواد ما
راي المواطنين الروس بمذكره الاعتقال
الصادره بحقه من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
راويه استنكار شعبي كبير لدى الشعب الروسي
من هذا الموضوع كاميرا العربيه تجولت يوم
امس في وسط مدينه موسكو بالقرب من الساحه
الحمراء في الشوارع الرئيسيه تحدثت مع
المواطنين من كافه الاعمار البعض منهم
يعني يخرج بضحكات استهتاريه حول هذا
الموضوع البعض منهم يتحدث بكل صراحه بان
لا موسكو ولا واشنطن تعترف بقرارات هذه
المحكمه البعض الاخر وصف الغرب
بالمجنون نوعا ما حسب وصفه وبان قرارات
هذه المحكمه هي هراء ولا يمكنها التاثير
على موسكو هو قرار طبعا لدعم البعض راحه
منهم يرى فيه لدعم سياسيا والبعض راح
يتحدث عن ان هذا القرار وهذه المذكره يعني
اعتقال الرئيس الروسي هي فقط للتشويش
وافساد زياره الرئيس الصيني الى موسكو
والتي تعول عليها الاخيره كثيرا في
الاعلان او في ايصال الرساله حول ولاده
قطب من الخاصره جديد في العالم راويه
وبالتالي ما اخر التحديثات
الميدانيه بما يخص معركه بخموت الصادره عن
الجانب الرسمي الروسي
يعني الجانب الرسمي الروسي في هذا الموضوع
ان كان على لسان بيان وزاره الدفاع او
سلطات المعنيه في هذا الموضوع والتي تقع
ضخمه لديهم تحدثوا عن ان قرابه كيلومتر
واحد تفصل الان قوات فاجنر عن مركز
المدينه الرئيسي ما زالت الاعمال هناك
تدور
بطرق او بشتى لكن باقل وتيره مما كانت
عليه على ما يبدو ان الجهه الشماليه
للمدينه تشهد نزوحا نوعا ما لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تعلن اي جهه رسميه روسيه
سيطرتها الكامله على مدينه باخمت ولم يعلن
الجانب الاوكراني بشكل رسمي ترك هذه
المدينه للقوات على ما يبدو ان الاسبوعين
القادمين راويه حسب قراءات المحللين
العسكريين في البلاد ستشهد سيطره على ضخمه
من قبل قوات فاجنر اذا عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
الوافيه حدثتنا من موسكو
ميدانيا اعلن رئيس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه يافرين عزمه على تجنيد 30 الف
مقاتل جديد بحلول منتصف مايو المقبل معلنا
ان مراكز توظيف مجموعه فاغنر افتتحت فروعا
فتنتين واربعين مدينه روسيه لتوظيف ما بين
5800 شخص في المتوسط يوميا ياتي هذا
القرار بعد تكبد فاجنر خسائر فادحه اثناء
قياده الجهود الروسيه للسيطره على مدينه
باخموت منذ قرابه العامه
اكدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان بخموت لا
تزال بؤره المواجهات العسكريه في المعارك
ضد روسيا واشارت في بيانها اليومي الى ان
القوات الروسيه شنت احد عشر هجوما صاروخيا
من بينها اربع هجمات استهدفت بني تحتيه
حيويه في زابوريا البيان ذكر ايضا ان سلاح
الجو الاوكراني استهدف سبعه مناطق انتشار
للقوات الروسيه بعشر ضربات جويه
وانضم الينا من اكياف الصحه في محمد
البابا اهلا بك محمد يعني ما وقع زياره
بوتين الى مناطق القرم تحديدا الى ماريوبل
على الداخل الاوكراني الرسمي تحديدا
نعم بالفعل ولكن مريوطل هي في مقاطعه
دونسك وليست في شبه جزيره القرم وكان يعني
كما يتداول في وسائل العلامه الاوكرانيه
ان هناك تشكيك بزياره بوتين الى داخل او
الى وسط مدينه ماريوبل ويعني بعض يعني
مصادر اعلاميه تتحدث ان زيارته كسرت على
احدى المنشات القريبه
منها انتقل عبر يعني بحر ازوف الى شبه
جزيره القرم في ساعات متاخره من يعني هذه
الليله زار الرئيس الروسي تلك المناطق
الجانب الاوكراني لم يعني ليس هناك اي
تعليق رسمي من الحكومه الاوكرانيه او من
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه وحتى وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه لتاكيد او نفي او تعليق على
زياره يعني بوتين الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كما يعني تسمى بالقانون
الاوكراني خاصه منطقه ماريوف او شبه جزيره
الكرم ولكن ما كان يتداول خلال اليومين
الماضيين ان القوات الاوكرانيه تست
باستعاده شبه جزيره القرن ونشرت يعني
وسائل الاعلام اوكرانيه اكثر من تقارير عن
يعني كلمات كان او مقاطع يذكرها الرئيس
الاوكراني خلال الفتره الماضيه ان شبه
جزيره القرن ستعود قبل نهايه هذا العام
الى الجانب الاوكراني بفعل انتصار
اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب وايضا بخير ودوليات
واندرير ايضا كان لهم خلال الفتره الماضيه
يعني مدير المكتب الرئاسي مستشار رئيس
الاوكراني كان لهم عاده خلال الفتره
الماضيه تاكيدات ان شبه جزيره القرم هي
اراضي اوكرانيه ولم ولا يعترفوا بيروسيه
شبه جزيره القرن ويؤكدون ان الجيش
الاوكراني سيكون بكل ما اوتي من قوه
الاستعاده هذه يعني المساحه الجغرافيه
الاوكرانيه الى اوكرانيا قبل نهايه هذا
العام وايضا يعني في بدايه هذا العام اطلق
عنوان ان هذا العام هو عام النصر في الحرب
او في يعني في الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
لاوكرانيا وان اوكرانيا ستنتصر وسي تحرير
جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه وايضا يعني
بالعوده الى الميدانيات والتي كانت يعني
مهمه خلال الساعات القليله المقبله القوات
الاوكرانيه يعني بالامس قصفت بمنظومات همز
مواقع عسكريه كبيره للقوات الروسيه بالقرب
من باقي وبدا تداول عدد من التسجيلات
الفيديو في وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه عن
يعني اليات عسكريه وحشد عسكري كبير للقوات
الاوكرانيه في اتجاه مدينه باخموت وان
الجيش الاوكراني اصبح قريب لبدء هجومه
المضاد لتحرير ضخمه ومنها لتحرير قطاع
الدومباس ايضا يعني القوات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه اكدت انها تستلم تدريجيا معظم
الاليات التي وعدت منها عبر يعني من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مثل اليات
براجلي وايضا منظومات صاروخيه ايضا الى
زخائر عسكريه خاصه ذخائر مدفعيه 155 التي
عان الجيش الاوكراني من نقص في هذه
الذخائر خلال الفتره الماضي الماضيه وايضا
كان هناك يعني وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اعلنت ان بولندا وسلوفاكيا ستقوم خلال
اسبوعين او ثلاثه اسابيع بتزويد اوكرانيا
بثلاثه وثلاثين مقاتلات من نوع 29 اضافه
الى تسع مقاتلات قد استلمتها اوكرانيا
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
ايضا فاجنر محمد تتحدث عن توظيف المزيد من
المجندين يعني ثلاثين الفا خلال شهرين هذا
هو الهدف
42 مدينه يعني هل هنالك من الجانب
الاوكراني المزيد من الحشد العسكري طلب
المزيد من الجنود هناك حديث ايضا عن
دبابات وتجهيزات عسكريه قادمه بحسب
المصادر الرسميه الاوكرانيه نعم بحسب
المصادر الرسميه الاوكرانيه يعني كان هناك
بيان لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بالامس
الهيئه الاركان في الجيش الاوكراني ووزاره
الاوكرانيه قالت ان يعني خسرت ما يزيد عن
عشرين الف مقاتل في فقط في محيط مدينه
بخمه يعني نقاط القتال من بين اهل الدار
وهذا يعني يؤكد التقارير التي كانت ترسلها
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن الاعداد كبيره
والضخمه للضحايا من وان تحاول تعويض
خسائرها بحمله تجنيد جديده ايضا يعني كان
يتداول في بعض وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه
ان مجموعه فارنير قد تتجه الى خارج
الاتحاد الروسي لتجنيد مقاتلين وخاصه من
بعض دول الشرق الاوسط وكان هناك تخوف ان
يكون هناك بعض الدول العربيه او سيكون
هناك حمله تجنيد في بعض الدول العربيه
لدعم القوات الروسيه الجانب الاوكراني
ارسل عده رسائل ان يعني من سياتي وسيقاتل
الى مجموعه الى يعني الى جانب القوات
الروسيه ومجموعه سيكون مصيره مصير العشرين
الف جندي الذين قتلوا منذ بدايه العام حتى
هذه حتى هذه اللحظه
شكرا جزيلا لك محمد البابا الصحفي حددتنا
من كياف
نشاهد معكم هذه الصور التي وصلتنا
لزياره بوتين لمركز قياده العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بروستوف
اذا نشاهد بوتين يلتقي قاده عسكريين في
اطار هذه الحمله
العسكريه ضد اوكرانيا كما تصفها روسيا
زياره للرئيس الروسيه فلاديمير بوتين الى
مركز قيادات العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
اخر كشفت مجله بوليتيكو الامريكيه ان خطط
الناتو الدفاعيه تواجه وضعا معقدا وذلك في
اطار التجهيز 300 الف مقاتل بالقرب من
الحدود مع روسيا ولفتت بوليسكو الى ان مثل
هذا العدد من الجنود يتطلب مئات الالاف من
انواع الذخيره والمعدات العسكريه وسيتعين
على دول الناتو المشاركه بتوفير الجنود
والطائرات والسفن والدبابات الامر الذي قد
يقود وحده الحلف بسبب التكاليف الباهظه
لتنفيذها بدوره حذر الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودي ميرسي الدول التي تساعد روسيا ضد
بلاده بان مصيرها العزله في العالم ولم
يحدد زيلينسكي في كلمه مسجله بثها عبر
حسابه على تويتر اسماء تلك الدول لكنه قال
ان من ضمنها دوله تزود روسيا بطائرات
مسيره من نوع شاهد في اشاره واضحه الى
ايران واضاف الرئيس الاوكراني ان هناك
مساعدات عسكريه جديده تشمل ذخيره ودبابات
ومدافع قادمه من كندا والمانيا وفرنسا
والدنمارك واستونيا وتواصل الاوساط
الرسميه والشعبيه في روسيا مشاهدينا رفضها
المطلق لقرار محكمه الجنايات الدوليه حول
اصدار مذكره اعتقال بحق الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على خلفيه الصراع
الاوكراني
صراع وعبد الاصابع بين موسكو والغرب يتحول
الى كسر عظام بين الطرفين بعد مذكره
اعتقال من الجنايات الدوليه تنال من زعيم
الكرملين مقامره غير محسوبه قابلت روسيا
حتى الان بالتقليل من شان هذه الخطوه
كونها غير معنيه بمحكمه لا تعترف بها
الرد غير ممكن على جنون الغرب وتصرفهم غير
عقلاني وهذا يعكس مرضهم العقلي المحكمه
الجنائيه لا تعترف بها لاموسكو ولا واشنطن
لذلك مناقشه القرار شيء فارغ نحن نفتخر
بزعيمنا العظيم على العالم ان يعرف هذا
الكثير سياسيه في البلاد تحدثت عن ان
اصدار مذكرات الاعتقال تم توقيتها مع
زياره الزعيم الصيني الى موسكو في العشرين
من الشهر الجاري زياره ترى فيها موسكو
خطوه هامه ورساله للغرب حول ولاده من
الخاصره لقطبي جديد في العالم
لن يكون لدينا رئيس هذا شيء مضحك نستنكر
هذا القرار طبعا
هذا ما يهمني كيف سيكون المستقبل خاصه مع
زياره الرئيس الصيني وكيف سيتصرف
ديبلوماسيون حيالها
في تركيبه لولايات المتحده وقرارات
المحكمه باطله ولا معنى لها بالنسبه
لروسيا قرار محكمه الله ومكان الوثيقه مع
محارم المهملات بهذه الطريقه وصفت موسكو
مذكره اعتقالي زعيم الكرملين عبد الجواد
الروشت العربيه موسكو
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
تحركات جمهوريه ضد اعتقال ترامب وشرطه
نيويورك تتاهب لاحتجاجات محتمله الثلاثاء
اهلا بكم من جديد اتهم رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكيه كيفن ماكارتي المدعه او المدعي
العام في منهات باساءه استخدام السلطه
والسعي الانتقام سياسي من الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دون ترامب
واشارثي الى انه سيقوم بتوجيه اللجان ذات
الصله للتحقيق على الفور فيما اذا كانت
الاموال الفيدراليه تستخدم لتخريب
الديمقراطيه عبر الملاحقات القضائيه ذات
الدوافع السياسيه وفي سياق متصل اعرب نائب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك بانس عنده
شمن توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب واصفا
محاكمته بانها ستكون مشحونه سياسيا ان
المدعي العام لمنهاات جعل من توجيه
الاتهام الى ترامب هو اولويته القصوى وهو
ما يكشف حقيقه اليسار الراديكالي في
امريكا على حد وصفه من جهتها اكدت اداره
شرطه نيويورك انها في حاله تاهب واستعداد
لمواجهه اي احتجاجات محتمله على خلفيه
نداء وجاه ترامب لمناصريه ودعوته لهم
للاحتجاج واضافت شرطه نيويورك انها ستبقى
على اتصال وتنسيق مع اجهزه انفاذ القانون
للمحافظه على السلامه العامه ولكن ننوه
الى هذا الخبر العاجل المحكمه الدستوريه
في الكويت تبطل الانتخابات مجلس الامه
لعام 2022
اعلان ترامب على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تروس سوشل بانه سيتم اعتقاله الثلاثاء
ومطالبته لانصاره بالتظاهر دعما له فجر
قنبله سياسيه في الاوساط الامريكيه تصريح
ترامب اعاد الى الاذهان مشهد السادس من
يناير واقتحام مبنى الكابيتال الامر الذي
استدعى استنفارا امنيا وقضائيا فالمسؤولون
في نيويورك ناقشوا الترتيبات الامنيه في
محكمه من هاتنا الجنائيه في حاله صدور
لائحه اتهام
تحت القانون ولكن ما يمكن ان يحصل في حال
ان حصل الادعاء واريد ان اوضح هنا ان
الادعاء يجب ان يصلي المحلفين واذا كان
هناك تصويت
فباغلبيه
[موسيقى]
يعني اتهام ترامب
رسميا يستطيع الرئيس ترامب ان يذهب بنفسه
الى المركز الشرطه وطبعا
يسلم نفسه
تصريحات ترامب قبلت على الفور بالمواقف
السياسيه الداعمه حتى اللحظه ففي الوقت
الذي اعتبر رئيس مجلس النواب كيف المكارتي
ان قرار اعتقالي ترامب ليس سوى اساءه
استخدام شنيعه للسلطه من قبل مكتب المدعي
العام سارع احد ابرز المنظمين لليله
الكابيتال علي الكسندر لتاييد ترامب
والاعلان عن استعداده لتنظيم مسيرات ترفض
قرار المدعي العام بحال صدوره
تواكب على الارض دائما ولكن ليس لهم دور
اساسي في هذا الموضوع الشرطه في نيويورك
لها الدور الاساسي وبداوا يتحضرون باي
محاولات شغب او لتظاهرات كبيره قد تؤدي
لاعمل
[تصفيق]
من المحتمل ان يجمع اعتقال ترامب اذا تم
الخطوات الروتينيه التي يواجهها كل متهم
من اخذ البصمات والتصوير مع كل الخصائص
الممنوحه لرئيس سابق كما يرافق جهاز
الخدمه السريه الامريكيه كل تحركاته
فيما اعتبر خبر اعتقال ترامب افضل هديه
يمكن ان يتلقاها المرشح الاول للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله لان القنبله الموقوته
تبقى في دعوه
بالتظاهر الامر الذي سيشكل نقطه نقاشات
حاده في الايام المقبله سليمان العربيه
واشنطن ونبقى في واشنطن ينضم الينا
الدكتور بول مرقس استاذ القانون الدولي
اهلا بك استاذ
بول يعني هل يمكن حقا اعتقال الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على خلفيه
هذه الاتهامات كما اعلن هو ام انه ما صرح
به قد يكون خطوه استباقيه للضغط على
المدعي العام في منهاتن
وعرقلت المسار القانوني
طبعا في المبدا نعم يمكن يمكن ذلك يعني
ليس هنالك حصانه بعد الان للرئيس الامريكي
السابق لديه سجل حافل من النزاعات
القضائيه المدنيه والماليه وسواها اليوم
الموضوع هو مالي ايضا يتعلق بتمويل وبتعلق
بحفلات فنيه وسواها من الموضوعات التي
يعني تزخر بها سجلات هذا الرجل وبالتالي
هو يحشد باتجاه امكانيه صدور هكذا اتهام
ولكن ذلك ليس مؤكدا يعني لم يتبلغ شيئا من
منهات نيويورك ليس هنالك اي فرضيه ثابته
هنالك شهود لا زالوا ربما قيد الاستماع
الاثنين هنالك شاهد اضافي ربما ايضا
سيستمع اليه هو الرئيس ترامب سواء بالحضور
شخصيا او عبر تقنيه الفيديو
دونما ان يحضر ويبني كل تحركاته على
التقارير الصحفيه يعني ليس هنالك معلومات
مؤكده انما ذلك في اطار الحشد الاستباقي
تمهيدا للقول ان اعتقاله هو امر صعب ويترك
ريول شعبيه وفوضى ربما وراء ذلك نعم استاذ
بول يعني
كثيرا ما ذكرت دعوه ترامبلي مناصريه
بالتظاهر
بالسادس من يناير واحداث
هذه ان تضع دونالد ترامب امام مسائله
قانونيه في المستقبل
نعم اذا كانت هذه الدعوه المتجدده قد ادت
الى فوضى وتخريب واقتحام لمباني عامه كما
حصل وهو امر مستبعد جدا يعني البارحه حتى
كان هنالك تخوف في العاصمه نفسها من
امكانيه يعني
احتشاد عدد كبير او قيام
اعتداءات لكن ذلك لم يحصل وكانت الشرطه قد
طوقت عدد كبير من المقر وقطعت شرايين
اساسيه داخل العاصمه يعني مما تسبب في
تلبك من قبل السكان هنا في كيفيه المرور
يضاف الى ذلك وجود ماراثون ايضا في
الرياضه
الركض لكن ذلك يعني طبعا في التدابير
التحسبيه اذا كنت يعني احسن القول او
للتحوط كذلك يحصل في نيويورك تحصل
اجتماعات امنيه تضم مختلف المتخصصه بما
فيها الفيدراليه وسواها للتحوط لامكانيه
وجود تداعيات شعبيه او امنيه
هذا من الناحيه الامنيه ولكن من الناحيه
القانونيه يعني ما السيناريو القانوني
المتوقع يعني لانه هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يتهم فيها دونالد ترامب يعني
بالتحريض على التظاهر التحريض على محصل
باحداث الكابيتال ماذا سيحصل الان برايك
تماما كنت ساخلص للقول
بالتمام انني اذهب للقول انه ليس هنالك
مؤشرات على حشود شعبيه تؤدي الى اقتحام
مقرات عامه والتخريب فيها وبالتالي ليس
هنالك مؤشرات على حدوث هذه العواقب اذا
اردت القول القانونيه التي جرت في السادس
من يناير طبعا الامر متعلق بخطوه السباقيه
للقول ان الاعتقال هو امر صعب وان الرجل
هو رقم صعب ذلك يرتبط ايضا بانتخابات
القادمه عام 2024 يذكر نعم بانتخابات 2020
لكنه لن اعتقد لن يترك تلك الصوره التي
تركتها احداث السادس من يناير في اليو اس
كابيتال من حيث التخريب
دخول المقر العنوه تاركه لا اعتقد انه
حاصل وبالتالي العواقب القانونيه هنا ليست
متوافره كما كانت عليه سابقا من واشنطن
اذن الدكتور بول مرقس استاذ القانون
الدولي شكرا جزيلا لك
ومشاهدينا مصادر العربيه تتحدث عن زياره
مرتقبه لرئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد الشاعر
السوداني الى تركيا وفيها عده ملفات
اقتصاديه وهي تحديدا يوم الثلاثاء وتستمر
ليومين نتابع بموضوع ترامب وكتاب رسائل
الى ترامب الذي يثير الجدل حتى قبل اصداره
بشكل رسمي حيث انا الكتاب الذي سيتم
اصداره الشهر القادم يستدرج اعتراضات
قانونيه ما دفع بعض السياسيين والفنانين
المدرجه رسائلهم في الكتاب لرفض نشر
رسائلهم الى ان نشرها بدون ترخيص من
مرسليها سيترتب عليه دعاوى قانونيه الا ان
الشركه الناشره للكتاب زعمت ان هناك اذنا
فعليا او ضمنيا من الذين ارسلوا الرسائل
ليتم تضمينها في الكتاب
افتت وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه ان امين مجلس
الامن القومي علي شمخاني سيوقع خلال
زيارته الى بغداد وثيقه التعاون امن مشترك
مع العراق مشيره الى ان الوثيقه جرى بحثها
منذ عده اشهر من جانب كبار المسؤولين
الامنيين في البلدين وكان شمخان وصل الى
بغداد صباح اليوم واستقبله قاسم الاعرجي
مستشار الامن القومي العراقي
نبقى في العراق حيث جدد رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد الشيعه السوداني التاكيد على
ان حكومته لن تتهاون مع اي تراجع او خلل
قد يتسبب باستغلال اموال الشعب لمصالح
ذاتيه او حزبيه او فيئويه واضاف في كلمه
له النجائحه الفساد تمثل المعركه الكبرى
هنا مع اي تراجع او تلكه او خلل قد يتسبب
باستغلال مال الشعر لمصالح ذاتيه او حزبيه
او فئويه فالثروه الوطنيه ملك ملك
العراقيين جميعا
وكل ذلك
يتوقف على عزمنا في مكافحه جائحه الفساد
تلك المعركه الكبرى التي انتهى ونا فيها
خسرنا كل معاركنا الاخرى
قائد العمليات المشتركه في العراق الفريق
الركن قيس المحمداوي في لقاء خاص للعربيه
شدد على ان تنظيم داعش كفكر وخلايا لا
يزال موجودا وان كان قد فقد الكثير من
قوته وقال ان القضاء على التنظيم بصوره
نهائيه يحتاج لوقت طويل
فكر وخلايا لازال موجود لكن نتحدث عن عام
22 و23 هو الافضل على مستوى استهداف هذه
المفارد هو الافضل على مستوى
استهداف قياداته وهنالك نضج في العمل
الاستخباري هذا مهم جدا
قياده العمليات المشتركه من خلال خليه
الاستهداف المتخصصه لمتابعه ومراقبه
الاهداف وفق معطيات ومعلومات من الوكالات
ثم جهد مراقبه فني حقيقه مهم جدا هذا
تحليل المعلومات وصولا الى تنفيذ ضربات
جويه مثلا في هذا الشهر فقط يعني من خلال
شهر يعني تقريبا 15 16 اذار الى يومنا هذا
تم قتل 43 عنصر من داعش اغلبهم او بهم
قيادات مهمه جدا
افاد نائب قائد العمليات المشتركه في
العراق الفريق الركن قيس المحمداوي في
لقاء خاص للعربيه ايضا ان بلاده قاتلت
نيابه عن العالم في الحرب ضد داعش حقيقه
موضوع داعشون الانتصار العسكري تحقق
العراق قاتل نيابه عن العالم انتصار باهر
وحتى وفق المعايير كانت تتصور العالم
المخططين المختصين والعمليه الطول لكن لها
الحمد بتظافر الجهود بعمليات كبيره رغم
كانت تضحيات انتصارنا على داعش يشهد لكل
العالم
بعد مرور عقدين على الغزو الامريكي للعراق
ادرك غالبيه الامريكيين ان الحرب التي
بداها بوش الابن كانت خاطئه وفقا
الاستطلاع اجراه موقع ابسوس وافاد الموقع
ان 61% من الامريكيين يرون ان الاداره
الامريكيه اتخذت القرار الخاطئ في ذلك
الوقت ان 67% لا يعتقدون ان الحرب في
العراق جعلت الولايات المتحده اكثر امنا
وفقا لتصويت موقع ابسوس
في العراق اذا عشرون عاما تمر على الغزو
الامريكي للبلاد حيث لا تزال التركيبه
السياسيه الشيعيه محافظه على مكانها
باعتبارها المستفيد الاول من سقوط نظام
صدام حسين وفق مراقبين للتطورات الحاصله
بعد عقدين من الزمن ما زالت تركيبه
السياسيه على حالها في العراق حتى مع
التغيير اتجاهاتها ومسمياتها الكتله
السياسيه الشيعيه المستفيد الاول من سقوط
نظام صدام حسين قبل 20 عاما وتكون حصه
الاسد من نصيبها في نظام ما بعد صدام فهي
اليوم باتت تمسك بمفاصل المشهد السياسي
برمته في العراق وتحت رقابه الحليفه ايران
وسط توازن هش ومتقلب محليا وحتى اقليميا
الصوره تبدو واضحه في الفضاء العام سواء
بصور رجال الدين العراقيين وغير العراقيين
المنتشره في كل الشوارع او من خلال احياء
المناسبات الدينيه التي كانت تقام بالسر
قبل عام 2003 هيمنه على الحياه السياسيه
بعد حرمان دام لفتره طويله من التمثيل
السياسي في ظل النظام القديم الذي اطاحت
به واشنطن حيث شرعت السلطات المؤقته التي
نصبتها الولايات المتحده في بناء نظام
سياسي جديد مع حلفائها واقامه توازن هش
للسلطه القائم على المحاصصه وتوزيع
المناصب بشكل رئيسي بين الشيعه والاكراد
والسنه مع نسب صغيره لبعض الاقليات
الدينيه والقوميه
طيله هذه الفتره هيمنه الاسماء نفسها على
البيت الشيعي وهي التسميه التي اطلقها
المراقبون على الطبقه السياسيه التقليديه
من نور المالك وهادي العامري وعمار الحكيم
والقائمه تطول كما ان اساسيات النظام لم
تتغير الى حد كبير فالقواعد التي ارسلتها
النخبه في عام 2003 وحتى 2005 ما زالت
تحكم الحياه السياسيه حتى الان
تضارب المصالح والبحث عن النفوذ داخل
اركان البيت الشعير دفع الخلافات للظهور
الى العلن لتبلغ ذروتها في اعقاب
الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره في عام 2021
لتتحول بعدها الى صدام مسلح على اسوار
المنطقه الخضراء في اغسطس 2022 بيوم من
القتال الدم في بغداد وما زال معظم
العراقيين الذين ولدوا بعد عام 2003 يمنون
النفس بدوله يحكمها القانون لينعموا
بخيرات هذا البلد الذي لم يعرف طعم
الاستقرار منذ زمن ليس بالقصير
ايام الحرب يعني والقصف كان يعني الرعب
واصوات الانفجارات واصوات الاطلاقات يعني
هذا كله يعني عشناه برعب احنا وبقلق يعني
والله حاليا يعني نفس الوضع ونفس النظام
الحالي والقبله ماكو فرق يعني مجرد ما
تتكلم او تخرج يعني وتطالب بحقوقك راح
يوجعوا يواجهوك بنفس المشكله
وراح يواجهوك بالسلاح وبالقتل يعني ماكو
فرق عن اللي قبله بالضبط
على الاحياء على المناطق ناس تدمرت طائرات
تضرب قصف هوايه صار القتل بالشارع صار
انتشر الدمار بالشارع
واعتقد انه هذا نتيجته اللي هو الكبت
والظلم اللي كان بالنظام السابق
[موسيقى]
تدعمه الشاين يعني
صدام حسين 48 ساعه لمغادره العراق
التاسع عشر من مارس 2003 جورج بوش يعلن
الحرب على العراق
العشرون من مارس 2003 بدء الغزو الامريكي
للعراق
التاسع من ابريل 2003 دخول القوات
الامريكيه بغداد واسقاط تمثال صدام الاول
مما يو 2003 جورج بوش يعلن انتصار امريكا
في العراق
الثالث عشر من ديسمبر 2003 اعتقال صدام
حسين
السابع عشر من يناير 2004 تقرير يقول
المعلومات عن اسلحه الدمار الشامل جميعها
تقريبا مغلوطه
من من نوفمبر 2004 هجوم امريكي على
الفلوجه بمشاركه نحو عشره الاف جندي
الثاني عشر من يناير 2005 البيت الابيض
يعلن عن انتهاء عمليات التفتيش دون العثور
على اسلحه الدمار الشامل
الثلاثون من ديسمبر 2006 اعدام صدام حسين
الشنقن
الحادي والثلاثين من اغسطس 2010
اوباما يعلن نهايه المهام القتاليه
الامريكيه في العراق
السادس من يوليو 2016
تقرير لجنه تشيلكوت حول حرب العراق يقول
المزاعم والاستخباراتيه حول تطوير العراق
لاسلحه الدمار الشامل كانت معيبه
ومن بغداد ينضم الينا فاضل ابو رغيف
الباحث في الشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه اهلا
بك سيد فاضل يعني بعد عشرين عاما على غزو
العراق ما الدروس المستفاده سياسيا وامنيا
نعم رايه تحيه طيبه لك ولمشاهدي قناتك
الكريمه يعني اولا انتظر العراقيون بصبر
فارغ انقضاء الحكم الذي دام اكثر من 35
سنه تمكن البعثيون منهم باحكام البلاد
بقبضه فولاذيه وتشرد بضع ملايين من
العراقيين في بلاد المهجر وبعد ذلك اصبح
الانقلاب المدومه بعد 2003 وعند تخوم
الحدود العراقيه دخلت القوات الامريكيه
وبسطت سطوتها وسيطرتها بالفعل المكون
الشيعي هو كان المستفاد الاكبر لكن سرعان
ما التحق بركبه بدء المكون الكردي ليتمم
المثلث الذي كان محتاجا الى يعني يجلس على
قوامه المكون السني كان هناك خطا جسيم في
عمليه يعني اتمام وانجاز الدستور العراقي
الدستور العراقي كتب بعجاله وهذه الكتابه
ادت الى اخطاء بالتاسيس بد ان هذا الدستور
يشوبه الكثير من النواقص بدليل انه في
اغلب مواده تذيل مفرده ينظم ذلك بقانون
افرزت العمليه عمليه التغيير حقيقه دخول
الديمقراطيه الى العراق كقطع الليله
المظلم بمعنى انها دخلت الينا على حين غره
لكن لم تدخل ادواتها لتكون عمليه التطبيق
والتنفيذ بطريقه صحيه لذلك لجات هذه الكتل
والاحزاب الى استحداث كانتونات لها فنشات
بدءا الطائفيه السياسيه السنه استلموا
البرلمان
والكردستان الجمهوريه والشيعه استلموا
رئاسه الوزراء فبدات المحسوبيه والمنسوبيه
تغرس انيابها وتنبت اظفارها في الوضع
السياسي لكن يعني هذا لا يخلو من انجازات
من بينها ان هناك تداول سلمي للسلطه من
بينها ان هناك انتخابات تحدث كل اربع سنين
حتى اذا حتى اذا حدث بهذه الانتخابات لكن
بالنتيجه هذا الانتقال السلمي للسلطه
واحده من صور الديمقراطيه حتى وان كانت
مقنعه لذلك اعتقد ان الاخطاء الجسيمه التي
المتواتره التي تعاقبت عليها الحكومات
المتعاقبه اعتقد تحتاج الى دراسه والى
تفصيل والى دراسه توخي هذه الاخطاء
بالمستقبل نعم راويه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من بغداد فاضل ابو رغيف الباحث في
الشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
مجلس السياده السودانيه وصفه بابتزاز
الميليشيات والبرهان يعلنوا عن حكومه
مدنيه قريبا تابعونا
اهلا بكم من جديد قال عضو مجلس السياده
السودانيه ياسر العطا انه لا مكان لفتره
انتقاليه فيها ما سماه ابتزازا من جانب
الميليشيات والقوى المسلحه في البلاد ونقل
بيان للقوات المسلحه السوداني عن العتقوله
انه لن يتم السماح بابتزاز القائد للدوله
ومؤسساتها واضاف العطا ان الفتره
الانتقاليه وقيادتها يجب الا تتعرض
للابتزاز بوجود الجيوش وميليشيات خارجه
سيادتها مشيرا الى ان الجيش السوداني قادر
على حسم اي تهديد داخلي او خارجي معتبرا
ان الجيش السوداني لا يستخدم تكتيكات
للاستمرار في الحكم واشدد العطاء انه لابد
من تحقيق الاستقرار في البلاد عبر قدر
اكبر من التوافق الوطني من القوى المدنيه
والمكون العسكري رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان قال ان
الجيش سيدعم الحكومه المدنيه المقبله
مؤكدا ان القوات المسلحه لن تتخلى عن
واجباتها واكد البرهان ان البلاد تسير عن
طريق تاسيس الحكم المدني مرشحا تشكيل
الحكومه المدنيه قريبا ومضيفا ان التسلط
من قبل الحاكم العسكري امر مرفوض وان من
يحكم سيكون حكمه بطريقه شرعيه
في اسرائيل لاحتشد الالاف من المتظاهرين
في عده مناطق للاسبوع الحادي عشر احتجاجا
على خطط تعديل نظام القضاء التي تسعى لها
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو حيث قام المتظاهرون
بترديد شعارات ضد خطه الحكومه اليمنيه
ورفعوا لافتات تحمل شعار الديمقراطيه
والمقاومه وطالبوا بسجن نتنياهو واستخدمت
الشرطه خراطيم المياه لتفريق متظاهرين
اغلق طريقا رئيسيا شمال اسرائيل من ناحيه
اخرى تستضيف مدينه شرم الشيخ المصريه لقاء
خماسيا بحضور مسؤولين من فلسطين واسرائيل
والولايات المتحده والاردن ومصر لبحثي
تطورات القضيه الفلسطينيه واليات التهدئه
ووقف اي تصعيد محتمل خلال شهر رمضان ياتي
هذا الاجتماع بعد اقل من شهر على لقاء
مماثل استضافته مدينه العقبه الاردنيه
الشهر الماضي ويشارك فيه مسؤولون امنيون
بارزون بينهم مستشار الامن القومي
هو من الجانب الاسرائيلي ايضا امين سر
لجنه التنفيذيه في منظمه التحرير حسين
الشيخ من الجانب الفلسطيني وتنضم الينا من
القاهره مديره مكتب القاهره مديره مكتب
العربيه رندا ابو العزم اهلا بك رنده يعني
اذا لقاء خماسي يعقد في شرم الشيخ اهم
الاسماء والاجتماعات
نعم راويه بحسب معالمنا هذا الاجتماع الذي
يبني على ما تم الاتفاق عليه في اجتماع
العقبه الذي عقد في السادس والعشرين من
فبراير الشهر الماضي بنفس الحضور الذي حضر
في الشهر الماضي يقومون بحضور اليوم كما
ذكرتي الجانب الامريكي المصري الاردني
الفلسطيني
كلها كلها بتبني على ما يتم الاتفاق عليه
ولكن اهم الخطوط العريضه من خلال هذا
الاجتماع هو خلق مناخ للحوار بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي وايقاف او محاوله
ايقاف اي اجراءات احاديه وهنا بتعني ايقاف
عمليات الاستيطان التي تقوم بها اسرائيل
بصوره مستمره ايضا كسر حلقه العنف
والتهدئه ومحاوله الوصول للتهدئه وخاصه
خلال شهر رمضان وبحسب معالمنا ان مصر
بتضغط للحصول على تعهدات من الجانب
الاسرائيلي او من الجانبين لعدم وجود اي
تصعيد خلال الشهر الحالي
وعمليه التهدئه هذه من ثم يمكن ان يتم
البناء عليها لايجاد موقف مستقبلا
لاستئناف عمليه السلام الحضور الاقليمي
والدولي هنا لتفعيل ايضا ومراقبه اي
اتفاقيات بيتم الاتفاق عليها في هذا
الاجتماع الاجتماع الاول في العقبه كان
مهم جدا لكزع الجمود وايضا لايقاف اي
عمليات عنف كانت متبادله او تبداها
اسرائيل او ترد عليها بعض الفصائل اذا هذا
الاجتماع من شانه الاساسي هو ايقاف
التصعيد حاليا وايجاده تهدئه هذا اجتماع
امني وسياسي سيتم الاتفاق على استئناف هذه
الاجتماعات مستقبلا بعد خروج البيان وبعد
انتهاء اجتماع اليوم تفضلي شكرا جزيلا لك
رنده ابو العزم مديره مكتب العربيه في
القاهره
انتقلت الشرطه الفرنسيه مشاهدينا 80
متظاهرا في باريس في احتجاجات تخللتها
اعمال شغب لليوم الثالث على التوالي
واستخدمت شرطه مكافحه الشغب الغاز المسيل
للدموع لتفريق المتظاهرين واشتبكت مع
البعض بعد اشعال النار في صناديق القمامه
وتمثل الاضرابات المتزايده اختار تحدي
لسلطه الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون وحكومته
بسبب قانون تعديل نظام التقاعد برفعه
عامين الى 64 عاما
انتهت النشره الى العناوين
للمره الاولى منذ بدء الحرب بوتين المطلوب
للجنائيه الدوليه يتجول في ماريوبول
نائب قائد العمليات المشتركه العراقيه
للعربيه نهايه داعش تحتاج لوقت
لقاء خماسي في شرم الشيخ لبحث التهدئه بين
الفلسطينيين واسرائيل بمشاركه امريكيه
وسط مناورات عسكريه بين واشنطن واصول
كوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخا باليستيا
واليابان تندد
الى اللقاء